c'est un chiffre qui alarme ces
dernières semaines alors qu'il avait été
d'abord évalué à 8,5 pour cent puis 9%
début avril
bruno le maire ministre de l'économie a
annoncé comme déficit public atteindrait
finalement cette année 9,4 pour cent
220 milliards d'euros 41 milliards de
plus que ce qui était prévu en loi de
finances initiale
tout cela s'explique forcément par la
tonne de mesures lancées par l'état pour
sauver les entreprises durant la crise
sanitaire
et pendant que nos déficits publics
augmentent revu à la hausse sans arrêt
la croissance n est toujours négative
le pib a encore reculé de 0,1 pour cent
au premier trimestre alors que là encore
le chiffre prévu était une augmentation
de 0 24%
mais qu'importe du côté de bercy au
maintien l'objectif de 5% de croissance
sur l'année
il faut dire que si aux états unis on a
récemment appris une augmentation de
l'inflation énorme et donc une
potentielle remontée prochaine des taux
d'intérêt de la fed pour freiner cette
inflation la bce elle a redit ya
quelques jours qu'elle allait maintenir
ses mesures de soutien coûte que coûte
et continuez donc à faire tourner la
planche à billets pour reprendre une
expression souvent entendue dans ces
caches
la france a donc encore nous pendent
centrale derrière elle et alors que le
dé confinement définitif approche il n'y
a plus qu'à espérer que cette fois ce
sera la bonne et que l'économie
redémarre vraiment comme semble le
penser le ministre de l'économie
hop
[Musique]